so who's your victim Chinese National  you had CCTV all over the flat  under the shooters have nowhere to be  seen  when by home office security minister  Isaac Turner good evening what's  happening correction is a method of  real-time image manipulation they kill  people  True Believer  you need to be careful shots fired  officer once again nothing died  it seems there are two Isaac Turners  which Isaac Turner should I believe  whoever's behind this is watching  everything we do  hacking my interviews and changing my  words where is  don't lie to me they are killing  dissidents and attacking our national  broadcast these are acts of Terror